cet instituteur détient un sésame le
passeport vers une application du
ministère de la santé
télécharger sur son portable si je veux
rentrer dans un salle de gym le théâtre
l'importer quoi je suis obligé de
montrer sa salle poste au revers on peut
pas rentrer alors vous le voyez en
israël
ils ont tous le passeport sanyi sorte
ils dansent au ive ont acheté des trucs
qui kiffe et nous eh ben hier le
commissaire européen en charge des
vaccins thierry breton a expliqué juste
ce que serait le passeport pour
l'instant explique scott s'arrête le
passeport voilà voilà voilà voilà on est
on explique serge passeports non ils ont
déjà voté leur passeport là nous on
expliquer ce que ça va être le passeport
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
oui mais mme asha 200 % d'accord avec
vous mais pardon nicolas mas je trouve
que tu es dans le déni et dans une
amnésie
moi je me souviens le nombre de débats
ici oh là là les arènes arn messagers
jamais de la vie les anti barça qui rit
les passeports vaccinale jamais de la
vie un passement vaccinale safran en
fait le problème c'est que le peuple
français et ne voulait pas en fait on ne
va pas tout mettre la gueule chose au
soir à cause du peuple français mais au
départ vous désolé si je vais vous dire
la vérité mais le peuple français c'est
clair si on leur explique les choses et
qu'on leur vienne à faire si on va faire
ça et qu'on les rassure et qu'on leur
dit en interne à la banque je peux vous
dire je suis déjà rassuré que je
comprends qu'on ferait si un jour on va
dire à faire un vaccin à bâle ont
finalement fait c'est pas mal ça en fait
on va prendre du doliprane en fait c'est
bon et puis le lendemain tu dis non mais
assez bon pour une ligne de conduite est
bouclée c'est possible quand même au
début on était d'accord
non c'est pas vrai non non non ont dû
aller chercher des gens pour pouvoir
actionner aussi vaccinale personnes
étaient contre non mais oui mais ces
hommes et oui la majorité était pourrait
voilà mais je voulais il faut que moi
moi je ne mettrai jamais la faute sur le
peuple français ça c'est vraiment dire
ça c'est quand il a eu des enseignants
pas d'armes ainsi que j'ai des mauvais
élèves
je suis pas d'accord on avait redit on a
merdé bernard montiel d'ailleurs dans le
même reportage et ils ont montré des
manifs
voilà qui vaccin très violente et très
important parce que tout le peuple
palestinien israélien n'a pas été
vaccinés voilà sur 9 millions il y en a
eu que 7 encore pour le moment tout le
monde n'a pas été vaccinés encore que
celle sur neuf et qui arrive avec sa
mallette et qui dit on à 10 bat pour les
vaccins il dort debout il au débat
d'idées gamme et nous allons deux années
là bas comme ici que si on refuse le
passeport vaccinale on va passer notre
temps à faire des tests pcr ou machin
pour prouver qu'on est négatif de c'est
sûr que si vous allez au restaurant de
samedi s'il faut faire un test le jeudi
pour voir si vous pouvez aller au
restaurant
on va être obligé du passé un stage chez
un patient hors d'eau hors d'irak
en ce qui concerne le passeport
vaccinale c'est vrai j'ai rallié nos
débuts on n'était pas tous choix de le
faire mais tu vois bien que cette
pandémie en fait pas bien la famille du
gouvernement ni le peuple donc ça veut
dire que nous saisirons n'était pas
chômé lendemain le peuple veut se dire
bah en fait si on veut le faire tourner
chance il va être tout le temps d'avis
on n'était pas chaud pour le confinement
yalala mars dernier la inzaghi indiqué
qu'il fallait faire un confinement tout
le monde a fermé sa gueule tout le monde
est resté chez moi donc tu dois encore
expliqué bien il faut faire le vaccin
intel tel vaccin c'est bon on a nous et
on y va
et vous allez sortir dans trois mois je
peux te dire que tout le monde aurait
dit oui
là on va se retrouver comme des cons et
je sais que le président qu'il devrait
parler mercredi soir c'est pas bon si
pas de mercredi soir c'est qu'il va
confiné complètement dans les écoles
c'est le bordel c'est le bordel partout
donc là faut prendre des décisions et je
pense qu'il faut tracer pendant deux
mois et bien voilà on va faire ça ça et
ça avec ses deux ça fait des semaines et
des semaines et des mois qu'on demande
bon mine de rien et des joueurs qu'on
demande on demande un calendrier très
serré la main de jean par ailleurs
qu'ils veulent pas vendre confirmé
écoles gilles voulait pas confirmé le
nombre d'années
des gens qui prennent des décisions
commence à prendre l'a dit tout le monde
mais ça même ici l'émission tu la fais
jamais rien qui va me dire tiens on va
prendre plus que reprendre ce à un
moment faut trancher je suis d'accord
avec vous c'est une bonne réponse à tous
ceux qui disent qu'il n'y a pas d'enjeu
financier autour des vaccins eux ils ont
payé le prix fort ils ont été servis
maintenant la diversion on a la
sensation qu'elle est réglé moi je
trouve ça bien de voir ça parce que ça
m'a un vrai coup de pression au
gouvernement par bon mais comment ils
vont annoncer mercredi soir un éventuel
reconfirmant alors qu'on voit que dans
certaines régions du monde non mais
c'est la tête
ils ont tué le gouverneur series et moi
même et alain je te dis franchement
c'est là des erreurs ou ce jeu
oui j'ai lu était d'ailleurs portage
totalement politique c'est un portage
pour dire en israël tout a été fait
merveilleusement le gouvernement a bien
agi les gens biens entre tf1 et le
président porterait plutôt oui mais il
va tout le temps parler là bas ça se
passe bien comment comment ils peuvent
faire ça je sais pas je sais pas j'ai
pas compris effectivement quand j'ai vu
moi-même j'ai été extrêmement choqué
jean louis c'est en israël donc les gens
écoutent le passeport vaccinale
on leur a expliqué ils ont compris les
données qui sont conférés aux
laboratoires c'est pas évident sa balle
à les israéliens ont tous accepté que
leurs données soient dans leur
laboratoire être la vaccination ou
presque tous
donc effectivement ça reportage
politique pour dire 'regardez voilà un
pays qui a su éduquer sa population
sous-entendu en france vous n'avez pas
pu donc se trouve ça extrêmement de sa
part extrêmement c'est un coup bas ce
qui se passe alors à moi j'ai trouvé ça
bien au contraire on met un petit peu le
nez du gouvernement
ben pour ne pas parler du gardon montre
justement ce qui se passe comment
mais oui mais tu as raison tiffany
watches h
mais on est ce coin c'est bien mais je
vous dis pour tf1 qui sont censés des
amis adorent ça se passe bien puisqu'il
parle tout le temps là bas et c'est je
pense c'est un combat moi je me paie à
la place de voilà du gouvernement et du
chef de l'état l'a quand je vois un
reportage comme ça nicolas attendait et
on en parle ici tout le temps je veux
dire le président de la république
encore le toit ou 10 il va jamais sur le
service public terrain est tout le temps
sur tf1
expliquez-moi stratégiquement comment
trois jours avant qu'un président
s'exprime surtout sur un sujet compliqué
on va aller montrer le paradis l'israël
l'exemple israël tout se passe bien là
bas on a des vaccins enfin à jaillir
stratégiquement et politiquement ou
pensez quoi
c'est quand même un signal qui est
envoyé au président c'est une
provocation c'est pourquoi je n'en sais
rien gentil on peut penser que c'est une
incitation à la vaccination est gentil
on est mauvais plus lucide que général